[Music]
good morning I think I should give you a
round of applause for showing up today
Sunday morning ten o'clock dedication so
well done as well
so yes I'm Guillaume been building
recommender systems in a few companies
in the past three years using really
leveraging the Python ecosystem so also
very thankful for well
the PI data the nun focus organization
for providing these amazing libraries
that I've used on my daily daily joggin
that are really a love using of also
using a using Scala built on top of the
world building recommender systems on
top of spark which is also an open
source project and that's also a amazing
piece of software so big big THANK to
people open-source software development
in general and people involved in these
projects and today I'll be talking about
how how the surge of deep learning
frameworks such as tens of Lewbert
there's also torch PI toge piano have
been a kind of a game changer in the way
I work and in the way we build
recommender systems to be honest 110 so
flu was released a year and a half ago
there was a bit of for me wasn't clear
whether I was specific to your image
recognition so really building and
training deep neural networks with the
convolutional layers and I thought it
was restricted to this use case and this
is because well that's where the biggest
gain appeared using a deep learning but
then actually looking intently at
tensorflow logo I realized I could
actually just use tensorflow
or any of the deep learning framework as
a kind of machine learning generic
library and but my favorite algorithm
which is matrix factorization may vary
use in recommender systems could
actually be be defined and trained using
using these deep low
frameworks that are just kind of
extension of numpy for example but with
the ability to run on the GPU and the
ability to benefit from a symbolic
differentiation or Auto differentiation
that I will cover later on but before I
would like just to give a quick recap on
recommender systems because you might
not all be familiar with this field so
the field which is also an academic
field with the conferences such as Iraq
sees and academic papers has kind of
came to popularity in 2008 with the
Netflix price when Netflix open sourced
a dataset of his of its users rating
movies and they started a contest asking
the community to come up with the
alternatives to beat there are internal
baseline to predict what a user what
rating a user will give to a movie he or
she hasn't seen yet so after this
contest actually the focus has moved
from explicit ratings so people telling
what how do I like this movie to
implicit feedback such as people viewing
items or content on a on a generic
website or people clicking or not
clicking on the recommendations
displayed on a widget on the site and
it's been used throughout the web
industry so amazon spotify youtube
pretty for computational advertisement
are the the main companies that main
visible companies using recommender
systems my company as well which is a
worldwide group owning a variety of
marketplaces and media houses
recommender system is a key part of our
the way we keep engaged with the users
and the way we will generate more
engagement and more more clicks and more
revenue ultimately just briefly so the
problem of recommender systems is to you
is can be boiled down as matrix
completion to we represent users as rows
of these big metrics and items are
content as columns and sometimes we have
already observed what the feedback of
the user with the content and sometimes
we haven't and the goal is to complete
to fill in the gaps so in this
particular example what's the value of
the the blue cell based on the
neighborhood the the ratings of similar
people or users and similar items and
the key assumption of the the most
popular method which is matrix
factorization is to say that we can
dramatically reduce the dimensionality
of this matrix this huge user item
matrix and we can kind of compress users
and items in a shared layton space where
the model says that the rating of the
user with for an item is actually the
cross-product of the representation of
the user and the item in the the shared
latent base on the terminology
recommender system the matrix actor
ization we use the temp actors for the
these vectors representing users or
items in the neural network community
it's named as embeddings and that's
really in touch and interchangeable name
this is exactly the same thing it's just
a dense representation of a of a f'n
entity into a latent space so it's paste
that is not directly attached to the
features to the input features so you
let the algorithm decide how we should
split the how we should map yourself
into this representation space of often
10 200,000 dimensions depending on the
domain domain the kind of
state-of-the-art methods for many years
has been this article it has two strong
points first of all it's able to deal
with implicit interactions don't know if
I can point but you see that the Pui is
not writing it's just a implicit
feedback so it could be a clique it
could be an on-click it could be a view
it could be you haven't viewed
the item and you can attach various
level of confidence to this to this
interaction which is a GUI part so it's
still root mean squared error based
trying to minimize some kind of not a
classification is trying to minimize
some kind of real value function but
with these confidence we're able to
express the fact that if someone click
on an item it's a strong positive
feedback but if you didn't click or
didn't view this is for example this
article which was displayed on the front
page we should give it a negative
feedback but slightly less the other
very strong point is in order to train
this model there's what's called the
alternating least square algorithm which
is fast and embarrassing well which is
fast and distributed because it's broken
down into two parts so first well every
step you train the user factors and the
item factors and when you train the user
factors you're able to paralyze the the
training of each individual user factor
and so you're able to do this in on the
cluster of nodes problem is there are no
very elegant way to add metadata so if
you know something from your user such
as the gender or the location and
similarly on the content if you know
what the genre of a movie there are no
clean way to incorporate this
information into a list there are ways
but they are hacky that's a problem
because in a real world setting we face
a huge churn of users or constantly new
users coming into the system for which
we know very little and ALS doesn't
learn very well to predict for these
users that's what we call the call
stocks in the literature and we can have
cool start for users as well as for
items for example currently I work on
meat or news recommendations what do you
do when you have a new article for which
no one has read or clicked you have to
rely on metadata on topics on the road
text on the category and the author what
not but you can't purely use clicks on
this particular item to your
to infer the factors of this this
particular piece of content one
improvement that was published by
Spotify is to well first make the model
a bit more elegant by turning while
still using a cross-product of user and
item factors X I and Y I I think there's
a typo it should be X U and Y you turn
this into a binary click prediction by
making the cross products
adding biases for use on items and then
slapping a sigmoid function to turn the
logit plug it into a probability so
being closer to what we are trying to
predict which is click using numpy the
inference for this model is a very
elegantly described so you see we have
kind of a direct mapping between the
formula above and the numpy code which
is to do the dot product of users adding
the biases and then applying the lodge's
by using numpy vector ability the way
the ability to work not only for a
single user but to work on a matrix of
users and by using the Broadcasting we
will to just buy one liner express' this
this complex formula that's great but in
order to train the algorithm well we
need to derive the gradient manually so
we need to do this math computation we
need to implement it in numpy that gets
a bit more verbose a bit more dirty and
I don't really expect you to read the
decoder is just an example to say that
yes inference is simple but deriving the
training algorithm is less is much more
verbose and we have also to take care of
the gradient step so we know the
gradients but how much we move whenever
we do an Airpark of training that has we
have to you to pick a strategy which can
be a degrade for example but that has to
be manually written in kind of very
imperative numpy code and personally
it's something I've never really felt
comfortable doing like I feel I should
be building machine learning
with them with the higher level
abstractions scikit-learn is great but I
can't for example reach this this level
of granularity so yeah I would like to
use these variations of recommender
systems but at the same time we work in
a company that can be a small start-up a
small company I don't have time or don't
have the confidence to make sure this
formula is correct
I don't want to spend some time
scratching my head thinking why does why
the algorithm doesn't doesn't converge
is it because of my implementation
because of my data that's I would like
to have I would like to be on the safe
side with respect to the tools I use and
this is why I think this picture was
being French and being born in Normandy
this was a truly a liberation for me
when when I discovered the the symbolic
computing and the auto differentiation
that all the deep learning frameworks
come with so I'm not talking
specifically about tensor flow here
torch piano trainer they all have this
disability that you described inference
part of your your algorithm and the rest
kind of comes for free with the caveat
obviously so the inference step first
glance much more verbal than in numpy
but and that's actually quite a often
third reproach about tensor flew very
verbose but actually most of it is
boilerplate code around scoping and if
we look closely we see that we have the
same building blocks as in numpy too we
have the unbending lookup it's
equivalent to do the slicing we were
using in Empire so based on a bunch of
user IDs will be looking we'll be
looking in the the factors matrix for
the the rows of these user IDs same for
the biases and then we have the item
product which is somewhere just a matrix
multiplication of the factors together
the addition of the IOC
is so verbose but very decorative kind
of bug well let's error-prone I'd say is
just declaring your model still kind of
a direct mapping with the math formula
but what I prefer to to look at is
actually from this declarative code
using the tinsel board you're able to
visualize the computational graph that
is created from these declarations so we
can see x and y are the the embeddings
of user and items the bias is B and T
and so we declare the graph it's
compiled and then at runtime what we'll
do is feed data into the graph through
the the placeholders so for for example
for a user one will pick the row in the
embedding X will have to excuse ur same
for the item will do the dot product add
the biases and then compute the log is
apply the Sigma reads and then compare
with the the ratings well actually the
ratings they should be binary because we
are computing a log loss and what
magical is once you've defined the
inference part of your model it's kind
of plug-and-play you just define in a
very in a short piece of code in a
one-liner you define well on top of your
log loss you define what should be the
what should be the optimizer what should
be the algorithm for stochastic gradient
descent so it can be Adam it can be
other great it can be many variants but
that's really plug-and-play it doesn't I
don't have to touch these codes based on
the optimizer I pick I can choose as
well watch what loss if I'm willing to
do writing prediction I can plug a mean
squared error loss without touching the
rest the bottom part of my code and
based on the optimizer based on the cost
function you see that attached here we
have that the framework will derive if I
have an error of X on the top part then
I need to back propagate this error to
the weight of the
the parameters of the model and this is
all done internally I don't have to
write this back propagation step I
already mentioned the flexibility and
that's exactly this once you have this
kind of simple model just using simple
factors for user IDs and item IDs well
it's very trivial to say well what if I
wanted to actually not only consider the
user ID but also the features of this
user and that's what this article is
doing is it's saying so the key formula
is here it's saying I want to consider
the user not only using a vector
specific to this user but also want to
say well let's take into account the
embedding for the general the embedding
for the age and so forth and so the
final representation of a user is the
sum of the embeddings
of his features or her features and the
same on the item side and then we just
do the classical dot product just a very
simple variant of matrix factorization
but that enables us to feed to take into
account features so very important
because seamlessly at recommendation
time for users that have a lot of
history we'll be able to use their
specific embeddings but if we have a new
user and we'll be able to actually
reconstruct a profile solely based on
the the metadata and if we have someone
in between well we will use a mix of
pictures and past actions the factors
learned on the path actions one
interesting extension is to turn the
recommendation problem from a binary
prediction into a multi-class
classification actually an extreme
multi-class classification where we're
trying to on the top of our neural
network try to have a Sun out try to
predict the probability of all the
possible items the the user can next
consume and so something really are keen
to work to fake
which has been developed on the disk
paper deep neural networks for you to
break say I see well it's just the last
layer the network is a soft marks that
funds out towards all possible next
videos a user can watch similarly to
word to fake but the bottom part of the
network is a deep neural network where
we're able to feed not only the user
features but also the past interactions
that's a key key idea of this paper
which was actually also developed in the
SVD plus plus model from the Netflix
price but it's reintroduced here in a
neural network from a family team so for
every sample in our dataset we're trying
to predict the watched WT based on the
history of not only watches but also
search history it's a really flexible
framework where you can feed Ferrari
signals into your system and this is a
kind of simple example of such a system
where based on my data sets actually I
haven't covered this but this is the
movie lengths 1 million data set so
ratings of movies from users but I'm
turning this into a more realistic
setting by a binary Singh the the
ratings I'm trying to predict what is
the next movie people will watch and
enjoy and so with this network it's it's
not shallow anymore because we're
combining factors for the users as we've
described before in the the first
architecture and we're also feeding
factors or embeddings for the user based
on the past history so this is a
representation of the user solely based
on the past movies this user liked and
because and because we might want to use
different size of embeddings for the
history and for the features we can't
directly do a cross product of these
this data so we use the flexibility of
neural networks by just concatenating
and having two
ten so based on the the embedding of the
user based on the features and the past
history concatenate these these data
together and then applying a non liner
layer to compute the final
representation of the user another
interesting bit of this idea is that
actually inputs that suddenly based on
the user so from there it's all
depending on the users past history
features and it's only at the topmost
layer that like we do in word to fake
we have embeddings of output items so
why is it important it's because and
this is the similar architecture the
full architecture from the neural
network for YouTube paper so the final
output of the model is actually just the
user representation which are non liner
combinations of history searches
geolocation gender age all information
about the user we condense this into a
single single vector that we then
compare to the item embedding the video
vectors by doing the cross-product and
in real time what we do is we don't feed
data into this complex neural network
what we do is we just use the embeddings
the computed embeddings we store them in
a some kind of database with the nearest
neighbor index and we turn the
recommendation problem into a search
problem we say I have a user or have for
example features of user I will pick the
representations of these features or of
this user in the last layer and I will
look in this latent space items that are
close by in this Laden space and this is
a very fast and efficient way to
retrieve quickly candidates for for
recommendations I'm going to demonstrate
this using the tensor board embedding
visualizer which is a tool to visualize
such embeddings
the key is these embeddings they're
typically of dimension 10200 thousands
it's not very easy to visualize them PCA
is one way to reduce the dimensionality
the dental board comes also with t-sne
which is a better way to compress to
visualize latent space of high
dimensionality into a type 2 dimensional
2d or 3d visualization it's better
because it tends to to create clusters
of points that are close together in the
original space so here we have each
point is a movie for which we have the
genre so it's not so clear but we have
on the bottom right we have I think
drama and drama and romance on the left
part we have a sci-fi and horror and at
recommendation time let's say we have a
user or which we know nothing except
it's a male and very dear wrote a
pejorative type Lee will pick near this
the embedding of the gender male we have
very manly movies such as Goldfinger
Full Metal Jacket and so forth yeah lots
of stereotypes because for women will
have well typical or romantic comedy
which actually more of my taste but say
that's a starting point what's
interesting is that we have the same for
the age and we can combine those so if
we have as a heuristic if we have
information about the gender and the age
then we could do just the sum the
average of these two embeddings and look
for something in between and more
interestingly for example if your last
viewed movie was something independent
something that doesn't tie to any
stereotypes then seamlessly we would
construct some kind of hybrid for
presentation of tissues are made of the
pictures and the last item seemed to
very efficiently retrieve candidates so
we have really a kind of seamless model
to tackle court recommendations from
that's also incorporating views and us
as as you view more and more movies
we're able to refine your profile as you
leave this step is just a pre candidate
selection there's another architecture
to more finely predict if you to
actually do the ranking so we use this
fast method to quickly retrieve
candidates and then there's another
architecture that is trained to rank the
final list to be a display to the user
so other conclusion well form it's these
deep learning frameworks have been
really a addition on top of the existing
ecosystem of our tensorflow and it's
really solved this problem of I want to
implement something from the literature
but as a applied data scientist working
a company I don't really have time to
debug the the math of very complex
gradient descent code which is very
error-prone we need to have some some
better abstractions to work and I think
that's really where a tensile force is
it's good is I want also to have some
guarantee when it comes to training
scaling and deployment and these are
tools I haven't really covered today
because that's a whole separate talks
but it's clear that tensorflow
and with the backup of Google is really
not only providing you the core blocks
to build your model but also the the
scaffolding to then deploy it train it
in an efficient manner
to be honest I've only scratched the
surface of what's possible in terms of
building recommender systems there are
many interesting approaches such as
instead of using the law gloss or the
cross entropolis
we could actually learn to rank directly
training our models trying to minimize a
cost function based on the actual list
your recommender not just a point wise
loss they're also wide and deep
recommend us a very good tutorial
visible where we kind of have a model
which is a mix of logistic regression
which is
we use for example in computational
advertisement with a deep part that use
embeddings and this model this hybrid
model is trained in combinations you
have really a hybrid model that is
trained in a 1 pipeline and the last the
last kind of architecture that I'm
actually investigate investigating
currently is how to incorporate time
into the mix how to incorporate the
sequence of actions that the user has
previously followed and this is very
interesting paper does this by taking
into account well user and time features
as well as actions and even more
interestingly it's able to do
recommendations predicting the next
action or the next content you will
consume but also when the user will come
back so it's tackling churn and
recommendation into a single
architecture which is a jointly trained
and this should be well I'm not going to
going to say fairly easy but using the
deep learning frameworks it should be
you have already the building blocks to
to build such architecture in principle
the lsdm cell it's a recurrent neural
network cell will be able to get
available as they kind of plug in in
these these frameworks that's it for
today thank you for listening to the
talk and if you have any questions thank
you very much it was a fantastic talk
have two questions first one would be
great to see some comparison of a ALS
and this message and what's the
improvement using this call features
user features not not only known not
only ratings second question is more
basic when you do this classifier you
need to have a sample so you use some
how would you build the sample you
probably would use users
some target if you clicks or not but
like if you not clicked what would you
include example thank you as a tool to
good questions in terms of a benchmark
it's something I wanted to get you to do
but I didn't have quite enough time I
did some offline calculation but the
problem is especially with the
recommender systems where in the end you
would like to optimize some online
metrics as you'd like to do an a/b test
a measure that you're improving pixel
rate or ideally engagement and it's
quite non-trivial to express this as a
offline benchmark and in reality many
papers I see published in the area they
make how you define your offline
evolution will is quite biased well by
doing so you you basically how much user
without metadata you have if you have
lots of if you have a very sparse
interaction matrix then features that
will be very important but if you don't
for example in the classic movie length
on Netflix they have only users with at
least 10 ratings and in this case yes
very cool for 10 ratings you might all
actually always prefer to use not use
the features but use the clicks so yes
it's hard to have a offline veg market
which is really representative of the
what you try to do online but I'm
working on this and what I expect is to
see that for a few clicks however if you
don't have much information then
pictures are important and then as soon
as you have more clicks a less is
probably possibly performing us as well
as they do shallow architecture and what
I'd like to see as all is well what I've
seen is the depths of the network is is
based on how heterogeneous are your
features if you have only one type of
feature then going deep is not really
interesting but if you're combining
history plus user features plus the
searches then that's when the
stacking the the non liner layers comes
as a as a benefit but definitely
practically in reality want to start
simple because because of this you might
over fit offline and realize your very
complex fancy deep network is actually
doing something very stupid online by
because it's capturing some pictures
that are not available like that happens
quite a lot so in practice is test
something shallow that it online and
then once you have some kind of feeling
that you're offline metrics is well
correlated with the online matrix then
you you go for the depth and yeah and
the second question was yeah
so either you do you have explicit
impressions for example this user was
displayed with these five
recommendations maybe you want to
capture some buyers of the position
possibly the topmost recommendation is
most mu stopped and clicked but then you
discount this positional bias and then
you feed these as direct binary targets
if you don't then you use negative
sampling so very similarly to work to
fake where you you can't if you if you
have a soft mark layer on the last term
you can't compute the denominator you
don't want to compute the denominator
which involves computing the scores for
every possible candidate items what you
do is you pick one positive and then ten
negatives and this is also quite tricky
because depending on how you pick the
negative samples that could affect how
well you will perform online and you
have a question
I was expecting a question about dental
fluorosis of potage say in one month to
ask what's ten slow-like compared to
plato's know do you do you do you use
tensorflow to serve your models live or
are you just using it here to train
these things and then you're using
something else for live so currently we
don't use it to live because it's quite
a engineering ly engineering wise it's a
quite a bit of work so what we do is we
pre compute factors or embeddings for
for features for specifically for users
and we try to use this idea to turn the
recommendation as a search problem
so there's actually this afternoon
there's a very interesting talk about
using an elastic search for
recommendations that will plan to attend
because that's what we're trying to
develop so well the first approach is
just to pre-compute recommendations for
you we we know you're an active user
so we'll kind of baked 10 or 100 of
candidates but that doesn't scale very
well if you have a large set of items or
if you have a lot of churn so the second
step is to turn recommendation of the
search problem and the last last step is
to do real-time scoring and we're kind
of in the middle in practice anyone else
like to ask questions
so the embeddings actually trained as
part of the these representations of FA
for example past past items there are
parameters of the models so you it's
like a blank slate that you initialize
randomly but thanks to the
backpropagation as you feed examples the
error will back propagate and these
embedding they will converge there will
self organize based on your or your
target that's kind of the magic of
matrix factorization works on a similar
idea actually so you just say well I
want to model my user as a ten or ten
twelve hundred dimension vector and some
of the items please organize yourself so
that I'm able to explain what movie you
will like and what movie will dislike
and what's interestingly is even if you
don't use any metadata is when you
inspect your embeddings you see that
there are correlations you see that
actually the network has used maybe a
few coordinates to model gender or to
model janar so you see that it's
learning in a very unsupervised way your
features but obviously if you're able to
feed these features as well it's like
speed up the learning but it's yeah it's
really known by the model the embedding
stuff coefficients are weights of the
model probably I really wanted trust
terms of flow versus PI torch here if
you really want to answer please answer
yeah
so the actually is good because it's I
don't want you to pretend to be a fun
boy of a time so for I think 10 so for
shines because of the the all the tools
that building on top fall outside next
to to 10 so flu but the declaration the
code declaration is a static so it's
really you you define your model using a
kind of DSL where you have the TF dot r
TF dot multiplication TF dot slice so
kind of replicating the capacities of
not by you declare your network and that
doesn't look like it looks it's Python
but it looks very kind of artificial
it's lazily computed so you do actually
nothing and then finally you you run the
data into your compiled graph so graph
statically compiled whereas using a kind
of DSL whereas pi toge is dynamically
compiled so it's much more you're able
to embed or mix number and pure Python
and Python code in a seamlessly so on
this I think a parrot tortures a feels a
bit more natural to to code and it feels
it's slightly better integrated 2g
ecosystem however both are using our
cepting numpy arrays as input think I'm
quite interested to to look more into pi
touch but currently doesn't have the
level of supports
although the additional goodies that the
tensile has thank you very much for you
if anyone else has a questions I'm sure
of it again we'll be around time to run
and give a warm round of applause again
[Applause]
you